I leave in are you on your way battle
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you claim give
us time and a terminal and gate we want
to send you off in style we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared was fine now
hahaha
do you meet around
it do you need a ride do you need a wine
do your me ride do you need a ride do
you need
with Karen and Chris today's episode is
brought to you by Squarespace start
building your website today at
squarespace.com enter the offer code do
you need a ride at checkout and get ten
percent off Squarespace build it
beautiful welcome to do you need a ride
this is Chris Fairbanks this is Karen
cool Gareth we're coming at you live on
a Super Bowl Sunday as we get on to the
174th apparently we've found the only
super bowl traffic I guess this is just
a line of cars of people that ran out of
tostitos liquefied cato oh it was
because there was a freeway car so you
don't you don't see those that often did
you see that car no oh yeah that guy was
just stopped in the middle of the
freeway walking around one just hit his
car he seems disoriented we should
probably go at least wander around with
him so he doesn't feel like such an
outcast that's a good idea so he's not
embarrassed yeah yeah just wander around
Jennifer also in shock the middle of a
freeway yeah just kind of walk in well
he actually was getting something out of
his trunk but didn't seem appropriate
it's probably just a gun it's like I've
had enough of this now's as good a time
as any Walter Super Bowl Sunday baby he
named his gun Walter I have fun I'm
watched I watched the beginning of the
game I'm on a commercial and I I want it
to air during the Super Bowl I'm not
sure why what commercial it's a subway
commercial Oh what are you doing oh I'm
reacting to a crazy news person who
thinks that something called sub me
gettin is occurring it's really just a
crowd of people at a subway excited
about the six dollar footlongs but this
news person
who is not playing the straight man
because she is just in winter clothes
and she said this you know it's putting
stress on the sidewalk things like that
and I walk out and I look at her like
well there's a crazy news lady and I get
in the car I don't say anything oh but
you do a lot of face acting yes and a
little back ting I am turn around get
into the car and a little back knee
because i'm shirtless in the scene
that's the secret you brought on stage
is that you have acne you always have to
bring something to your chair occur and
I brought some back knee just big just
just sores maybe open weeping sores on
your back the first thing I said to the
director as I feel this character should
be shirtless he said let's do it he said
I want to play with it I want let's play
with the scene yeah he said play with
that riff if you will that's awesome yes
with your eyes it was fun it's funny
though you do something like that and
I've never gotten so many people texting
me and saying oh I just did I just see
you in a subway ad it's exciting I see
my friends off very often in commercials
and
I shout it out when I see it should I go
right or left I think left there's a
graffiti on the sign which I think that
it's important as a graffiti artist to
establish ownership of a sign I
understand that you want to have as many
signs on your turf as possible but the
truth I don't know what those lunatics
are thinking I just need to know north
or south and you put a z-boy this is
sherman way is devoid some area though
you know I hope we don't run into him
got me to spring you right in the face
what if he is actually shaped like a Z
like he has terrible posture he's always
kneeling me that's why they call me z
boy cuz of my scoliosis don't say
anything about my breeze he's starts
crying oh i am sorry i'm gonna turn off
my thing oh good idea yeah let's it
let's all agree you and I and the
audience let's not take phone calls
during this episode yeah can we please
elec I'm sorry to be like a stickler
about rules but that goes for you at
home yeah everybody please please no
phone calls we're begging do not pause
this even it has to happen real time
even if it seems urgent and was prefaced
by a text that says please pick up when
I call oh my god there's so much blood
yes do not answer the phone just let us
have our time with you it's an important
episode this is the episode where we
figure it out yeah and oh you have to be
all selfish and talk to your meemaw ano
didn't do you know what was that song I
don't know I don't know the n.o so I'm
sorry I think I hate that when I bail on
you like this comedic Lee you're
supposed to say you do know the song no
matter what yeah that's the rule I
knowed you I know it's a
against the rules of improv I actually
don't really know what song I'm singing
either well I'm going to have you
reaching it and hold my shaz I am up to
your face oh good idea and then I'm
gonna do something with that phone app
I'm gonna be such a great dad jokes like
that but it's gonna be so much fun it's
gonna be so much fun guys I do really
want to describe the skyline right now
because it's kind of like the Sun has
gone down but this guy is still yellow
turning blue I think that's a mob am I
wrong uh no mob is more purple yeah
purplish grey I was testing you okay
Karen I wish I went to art school yes
thank you for one you one I want
everything yeah you want everything I
one art school even though I never went
to I flunked out of college you won a
degree from art school all right you get
a degree from our school I have a
bachelor's degree in fine arts with an
emphasis in drawing is it true yes yes
so that's crazy i could know that yes i
could put a bee after my name that
stands for bachelor I think technically
I can until you get married yeah well
then you have to rip up all of your
educational certificates yeah so sad mmm
or keep them in the den the only place
where I can be myself oh the Dan cave do
you think that man caves are out at this
point uh the phrase I hope I mean like
just the concept of it you think that's
out do you think feminism is beaten down
man caves I'm I hate to bring this news
but i don't think so i think man caves
are here to stay Karen you I mean I feel
I understand that ma'am met man want to
get away it's weird and and I you know I
don't care about football but I there is
something missing cuz I know I'm missing
the game in it I have thought about it a
few times like you wish you knew what
was going on wish I had friends and I
wish that we were all sitting and
watching you know peripheral e watching
this football game
we set some goals for next year at this
time next year um go this time next year
exactly i'm going to watch the superbowl
we're gonna watch a Super Bowl and
before that fine friends yeah you have a
full here to find friends mm-hmm and and
I would really suggest that you don't
just look for football friends because
that might take you down a path you
don't want to all right on per se yeah
and then no one's gonna bring elegant
dishes which is important no they'll
just be roided-out and snapping
everything in half mm-hmm don't get I'm
just saying keep your eyes open don't
get a bunch of slim jim buddies now the
amount of salt that'll be at that party
if you only have slim jim friends
dangerous i don't want to think about it
no we're all gonna leave with kidney
stones yeah I think I think that's what
kidney stone is it's a salt deposit if
i'm not mistaken i heard actually sons
are just they're tiny pieces of beef
jerky oh that did with fingernails
grinder aliens yeah yeah you didn't know
that no no that sounds like a aqua teen
hunger force Aquitania deporting yet
that's what it used to be originally it
was supposed to be in Jamaica aqua teen
hunger force mom and what would the
theme song sound like you know
everything it would sound like poo poo
poo poo eat a piece of these junkies
jerk chicken who you calling a jerk
right oh god I can't wait embarrassed
kids you were going to I'm so
embarrassed right now and I'm incredibly
old one time my dad it was like a
parent-teacher conference or something
he pulled his pants up and I do believe
I'd recall him falling down stairs on
purpose just to make the other kids
parents laugh oh that's genius yeah even
acted hurt people ran over are you okay
mr. Fairbanks then they got it right in
the face with a squirting flower
no one ever caught on that that cute big
huge Daisy that he was wearing pin to a
tee shirt was a squirting flower no one
knew everybody met he said oh this don't
mind this I'm just in the gardening or
mi squares were right in the eye right
in the open I good times yeah they were
the best of times um so the next big
light you're gonna go right okay cool um
we're heading over to Jack equations
house she's done us a huge favor of
being on this podcast with us we love
her and she's one of our favorite guests
yes but also it is super bowl sunday
yeah so it's kind of like we're cutting
into it national holiday I think if
sorry not this if the Green Bay Packers
were in the Super Bowl she would not be
available but like a lot of things right
you know no one cares about these teams
um today is the Denver Bronco fighting
Broncos are going pitted against the
North Carolina lurking Ravens Panthers
Panthers yessir is these that was a see
there we go now everyone knows for sure
that I don't follow football well but
you will next year mm-hmm who are the
Ravens uh Baltimore ah yes and I don't
also follow football but I just had to
work on that pilot where it was all
sports the quarterback is Joe Flacco for
the Ravens just so I can all of a sudden
gain back some points okay that's gonna
that's gonna get you pretty far I only
know that because I was in a tissy
tito's commercial oh that's right yeah I
drop a bag of chips and right when I
bend over to get him he sees it as an
opportunity to confuse it for a hike and
he gets behind me he goes blue 42 and I
just say timeout it's a funny miss his
hands are under falls yes yes because
I'm homophobe my character was
homophobic sure well or just maybe you
know there is that thing where you just
maybe don't want people's hands near
your junk you know that is what the
thing was cuz I'm not saying I wasn't
attracted to the man yeah remember you
talking about what it's true specimen
yeah that's a physical specimen and a
very disarming he was
shy and I'm i guess i'll add handsome
why not why wouldn't i probably should
have been the first thing i mentioned
that's kind of a given though because i
think we talked about this on that
episode but those people who've
dedicated their lives to sports are
gorgeous simply by the fact that they
don't have an ounce of fat on their body
Ryan they're just they're just what car
do looks like as a person I'm gonna I'm
gonna look like that one day I'm gonna
get a new hip and I'm going new Oh
should I turn left not here oh yeah so
I'm sorry I didn't realize we were there
okay sorry we're trying to be tricky
about you how to specifically get to
Jackie's house and in doing so I'm
almost making Chris crash this is not
quite all right it's just how we do it
once again Chris's driver and sound man
um today grandpa I just said that to 20
year old okay it's always the Ford
Aerostars it is big now there's an
American car that's exactly what you've
been looking for tailored nuts today
wrinkles good lord okay and this is
familiar I feel like we're in we're in k
Shinto territory yeah this is it's a
real suburban part of I think this is
van nuys technically all right I can say
the city right yes okay yes
you're going to have a great time I
don't want to spoil anything but she I
think wants to talk about girl scouts oh
so I'll save everything I have to say
about that for that moment good idea if
she doesn't mention it I'm gonna bring
it up to don't you worry good plan ah I
just actually had coffee with Jackie the
other day oh really what did you talk
about wow I can't I'm not at liberty to
say oh it's down oh but Aaron Foley and
I who's another great comic who also god
dammit don't know I'm right I'm right
sorry it's here okay uh I went to coffee
with Aaron Foley and as i'm texting her
to tell her I'm late which I always am
she's saying it's fine because Jackie
case is already here so then we all had
coffee oh well it was wonderful sounds
fun you just pull up and just start
honking yeah let's just like it she's
just waiting she's just sitting on her
front porch way oh my goodness she is
this is almost embarrassing well it'll
be fun what did she expect us to be here
sooner yes everyone always is we're
always late all right we are always late
it's hard I had to get gas had to get
batteries we're sorry we're late we're
finally here she's upset she's upset no
she's no she's not
did you get to see Beyonce why not oh
okay good it wasn't it no one took it
away from you good that's what I'm
checking on that we didn't ruin your
evening oh hey guys hey Jackie sorry but
just things came up we had to get
batteries we had to get gas we had to
get gas and battery need to get our [ __ ]
together there's books and back here
that's yeah if you get bored don't don't
be afraid it's just free to read a book
about Elvis and then in a little Mike
next year or did I blow that oh you just
tapped it oh it's it is right right
under your this side up right here okay
possibly too loud yeah um yeah I'm gonna
there we turn that down there we go what
I sound like what i was talking there
she is Jackie case occupation thank you
guys thank you for getting inside the
Honda hi this is a beautiful honda i
meant Nell discussed a little unfaithful
music he is a little unfaithful than
Elvis Costello oh yeah I have a book
back there yeah he doesn't he doesn't
eat a stick to the script no he's like
dude you were asked a guy weren't you or
what was his buzz hey I think with what
was his buzz daddy Jackie's into jazz I
think he was one of those scott cats
wasn't he was he was he I I listen to
that my aim is true business is that
young yes you're right huge fan weirdly
enough i'm going to see him are you
really in april yeah i would love to see
him I'm a big big fan you have to go to
Orange County that's her
has been kept on am because of coffee in
a cage yeah do you need coffee yeah yeah
let's go get some [ __ ] ok ok let us we
should have brought you some sorry sir i
know i need to actually Chris it's Super
Bowl Sunday you guys that's right and um
so what so what the hell what's the
journey gonna be like there's less
traffic I found that so far people are
driving at us at a superbowl rate which
is nonchalant if you guys see something
say something yeah I am there's an LED
readout somewhere on my way that is you
that if someone's driving drunk if you
could knock out I'm quick you no matter
what you see tell somebody yes even if
it's boring that I saw a guy in a roof
it's not a tmobile store have you guys
see look Oh sometimes Susa there's one
of those those floppy things here on
this corner see the tiny should I turn
right or head you're right oh let's do
it oh there's a human she's on her way
to an after party for the superbowl
bring it lady we're across the street
from my papa que rico used to be a check
cashing place and now it is a grilled
chicken place oh it's really good that's
good and you could still cash a check
probably I like there's pictures on the
sign uh always a good always a good time
they look like was that an army man on
the sign for a chicken restaurant I
don't think it wasn't our remand k
mm-hmm I think it's army guy oh oh I see
you can hang it right up here mm-hmm can
I do it the starbucks nice to starbucks
in an hour to serve oh that's right you
guys just went it if we should have
texted ahead for your for your order my
order we are very selfish I thought we
were gonna I thought we were gonna go to
I thought you guys were giving me a ride
to starbucks we that's what's happening
yeah that's totally what's happening I'm
you did mention coffee beans did you
want to buy beans in bulk dude you can
you get through that at starbucks hey
you can you could buy out you can play
beans
what if you like on your more of a
person who prefers ground oh I have them
grind them Alan grinder yeah they'll do
it was a short-lived day when I wanted
to grind my own beans and sort of live
that life that ended quickly ended very
quickly it's kind of a pain you don't
expect the whole lifestyle that goes
along with it yeah there's a huge
commitment earth of tiny painful sniff
grunt grunt beans and the grinding and
then a mess coffee dust yep you have to
wear a lot of issue [ __ ] smocks oh
yeah and gold panners too yeah that's
right drug addicts right they all call
it that they all do i use a coffee
grinder on beans um and it's very loud
it's super loud it's the other so
obnoxious you know that Andy Kindler has
one of those bulbs those water bulb
things did you see it like
intelligentsia blue but is he's got a
fancy coffee situation going on like a
pour-over deals just button but more
than that it there was a wordy to
upcoming episode of the dark forest feel
free to listening talk to me about what
I could only say it sounds like a beaker
of some okay is it a clover machine I'm
just gonna keep guessing right now I
think it's a four-leaf clover machine
and it's super lucky if you ain't ya hey
you have the best coffee in the world
did he just tell you about it or did you
see it no he just told me about it was
me emin Bobby Tisdale and Bobby today I
wanted to talk about breakfast so Andy
Kindler would off on a coffee Jay what
he minute oh great I like when he goes
off on Jags I once heard him go off on a
Jag about the TV show jam and that never
end it seemed like it was never gonna
end much like the TV show jag did you do
go on little note little-known spinoff
NCIS oh that's right cuz im so many
military mysteries i would have thought
that NCIS was a tone spend escape from
the mind of Zeus yeah but you know why
you think that cuz Mark Harmon baby he
makes you he's the be all end all i'd
say i believe i read somewhere that he
is the high
paid actor in television that would make
sense because NCIS has been on for at
least 10 year 13 years as is that true a
long time long time it's been I wanted
to find out that you were crazy huge fan
of NCAA I am actually a fan of NCIS I am
too i watched a ton of them one year I
laid on the couch for a naughty one
straight years I got back to back to
back yeah were in a row and then
whatever afternoons dirty yeah the guy
nobody lifestyle the funny guy yeah
whatever his name is real hair cut your
hair cut okay and the girl that's from
the Israel yep the two of them I we ate
breakfast when they were at hugo's one
day okay they were wearing very fancy
clothes yeah and then a couple days
later I saw them in those clothes on the
cover of TV Guide magazine you were
going for oh god see stuff to eat before
a shoot I know what do you think it was
after it could have been after but I
think they were I think it was after
because they had very light a light
hearted energy about them they weren't
they seem to be relaxed after can tell
you about the strip mall okay guys
before we we should sit here and doctor
that's a lot of I love it this is this
is this kyushu ramen place next to this
hanabishi japanese place yeah is all one
place todos african cuisine by the way
oh my god you guys at the veins todos
african cuisine i love that it's called
todos I mean that's an inside joke isn't
it I enjoyed what though it's an Africa
well there's it a todo has a song called
Africa oh that's yeah arias yeah that it
is all I know is that the one time I
went to the African cuisine I've never
seen it open since they had a dish that
was get this it was a bowl full of
chicken legs just a bowl of lamb chicken
leg sticking out of a broth leg up leg
up you guys know yeah did you eat that
oh yeah i'll leave the chicken but the
did it still have the talons no no
that's what I imagined yeah it was so
drumsticks I know it's some sick i don't
know why i had i think it's almost
racist that we assume the times were a
tad I think you were definitely what I
guess it is my racism was it from an
outdoor
a wagon were you also buying edited dvds
are there a lot of soldiers nearby
whenever you walk in to those African
cuisine a twelve-year-old hands you a
bag of starburst and you have to watch
rambo terrible and then blood diamonds
the blood yeah that apartheid again
again again with the apartheid [ __ ]
we're parked in front of an overpriced
topless and we're around a bunch of
dudes that no doubt vape and have
hoverboards oh yeah not the so
misleading i have to talk about these a
little glow in the dark segways that are
called hoverboards yeah they aren't
hoverboards no that would be a
skateboard from Back to the Future then
that would offers hoverboard it's a new
Segway thing and it comes with a vape
pen essentially too it's a segway
without without the scoop that arms yeah
but sorry does it really come with a
vape penny that's your job I just
everyone that I see on them is also
vaping it's not seen in multiple time
they glow in the dark sleeping Oklahoma
Dirk feet you have to have a vape pen
that glows the same color as your glow
in the dark hoverboard what's the mist
that you're that you're sucking up its
vapor but I think often times it is
loosely related to antifreeze as far as
I've oh you can only hope I remember my
introduction to vaping was front row
some comedy club dude in slippers and
love his pomegranate missed in my face
ah and it was pomegranate flavor does
like not okay it not okay I'm Carrie and
that man was Owen Wilson why why would
you do it cuz a zoo in or two oh wow
wait a minute okay can you guys remind
me did it Owen Wilson attempt suicide
yes when it was probably 10 years ago
okay okay so he I was at a party once
yeah and this offering what's that turn
it off oh okay yeah um and Owen Wilson
showed up with Luke Wilson and they have
a third brother get his party someone
took their picture and the third brother
that isn't in a lot
movies punch the guy in the face whoa
don't take pictures of my brother and I
the guy was like um it's my house it's a
party and some famous people showed up
so I thought I'd take a picture of them
I wasn't like this kid didn't know that
he had just attempted suicide so you
know my cap opera I'm the first one to
come at you with some negative Wilson
news yeah but that's just that third
brother imagine his life well I don't
think Owen and Luke were like you
shouldn't have done that older brother
they were like yeah and then they only
laughs Chris Hemsworth guy has the third
brother oh what's he look like he looks
exactly like the other two treatments he
just might must not be as unshakably
talented I think he's I think he's like
1700 now he's gonna grow four more
inches and become the hottest guy who
isn't his own brothers I always think
about in those in those like hot guy
families acting families yeah I always
think about their mothers best friends
family there's probably some dorky girl
that had to go eat dinner at their house
all the time that was just like
literally on fire with shame and
embarrassment being even just sitting at
the table yeah just horrified that and
then and then secretly dreaming that one
day one of them might one day notice her
yes it never happens like we can't go to
the hems what's I have a sit mommy
please know it you're dressed put your
jumper on we're going to the Hemsworth
sir any way that I get a diuretic before
we go we have to go to the lake with
them again can you imagine or just the
Owen brought the Wilson brothers imagine
River Phoenix and his brother tree
Joaquin and Joaquin and who's used to be
leaf I can guess what you're thinking
it's worth I'm in show business but I'm
not the shoe business part that knows
who anyone is I prefer to stay behind
the scene that's where all the good guys
Carl lives of show business I'm not a
tears the final rose McManus of America
McLaughlin report wait
it um I'm just trying to riff now it so
call apart I do it and I I want to
apologize right now I've been so quiet
I'd really again when it's Twilight like
is it Twilight it's almost dark yeah I
time yeah I get so nervous in the car do
you owe like his the changes just my
podcast character I guess I mean I was
are you sweating from just changing
lanes and getting into the slot and I'm
just now starting to feel like myself
well and also you have to you're doing
two maybe even three things right now
yeah well we're not now but we were I am
kind of multitasking but only in my
brain which is even worse because
there's nothing I can do to change
anything hey there's a football game
playing in the background did you see
that oh look hey it's the Broncos wow
we're watching the Super Bowl I love it
with me watching the super early in the
party 150th year right now and I don't
want it well it's not a spoiler this
will come out to tomorrow Denver is up
to 16 carolina trailing behind at seven
we're in the corner just five minutes of
the third quarter we have missed the
halftime show there has been a fun hold
right now they are they're scrambling
around it it looks like he's been stung
by bees there's a guy was run digging
his face into the ground like he was a
dog covered in bees but everything's
okay and I assume he wasn't covered in
bees yeah this is it this is the way to
watch the game it is the way to swing
through your car it's like a driving so
we're near this unmarked coffee place
did you really want to go in and get
some grounds we can like pause yeah well
pausa for you and it'll be a moment
where I but a advertisement yeah well
our commercial here that'll be good
enough okay yerba we'll do it right here
okay I shall return squarespace.com is a
place where you can go to learn how to
build a website a portfolio or an online
store they have the tools the templates
and the instructions on how to do it i
went with a kind of famous competitor
when I made my website and I have to say
Squarespace is easier to use and they
have way cooler templates the sites look
professionally designed regardless of
your skill level there's no coding
required no HTML if that
still a thing it's intuitive and the
tools are easy to use and you get a free
domain if you sign up for a year so when
you sign up with squarespace make sure
to use the offer code do you need a ride
to get ten percent off your first
purchase Squarespace build it beautiful
and we're back I just want to cough into
it before right with you yeah I think we
got ideal into the cuff that's people
like um podcast to be real and gritty
and that's verte it's what they call it
so Jackie bought some beans what how did
you make your choices in there is there
anything exciting happen here's the most
exciting thing I said you guys have any
Indonesian coffee mm-hmm and the guy
goes well we have Kenya is that into no
no he said that i don't i don't think so
i said okay that's and then he comes
back in like three seconds that he goes
Sumatra and I was like yeah yeah that's
an Indonesia and the other the other
barista goes see the great thing about
this job you learn your geography it's
nice it's they did you really say no
that's okay yeah I did he totally busted
on his on his coworker ah that's very
positive that's the one thing I miss
about being a barista as everyone was
busting each other's balls and insurance
buzzer at the into their dental that
came along with it I mean it's such a
miracle but starbucks actually provides
benefits for their employees imagine
imagine i'm at i can't actually uh I
haven't had a good anything with with
any sort of benefits uh in a dozen years
yeah yeah Your Honor on with that hey
this guy has a tiny prop whew yeah
that's a good idea that's just a prop
winners shiny yeah there's no nozzle on
it and yes there's no way that that's
actually to be used no no no and I you
know he's coming our way next yeah but
it's not gonna happen is it no I'm gonna
stare over at the CVS sign like I'm
trying to read something small on it oh
that guy's we just got a buck she did of
course he dado now he's looking in there
what else you got in there Ressa can I
have a bite thumbs
yeah yeah I have a bite can I have a
buyer that sandwich thank God it's green
we don't have to watch ignore that
you're in the road for God's sake those
people I you always hear those stories
of like how people that Panhandle like
that make like two thousand dollars a
day right right I just keep that in mind
I like to tell myself that makes myself
makes me feel better why don't ya it is
weird even though we do have a guy we
could take a little Drive fine there's a
guy lives in front of my 7-11 I think
about him every time someone spent
eighty dollars on their dog yeah yeah
yeah there is people do so say that and
I I tend to think no they don't man
blood and the humiliation of begging
might be worth to them right just a day
that's what I was gonna tell ya it's
like uh you are you're earning that and
there was one time though that I saw the
ID hey you're right the Venice
rollerblading guitar guy um he's famous
I mean he's big he had a very nice car
he was getting into a very nice Mercedes
yeah that guy works good 8 12 hour days
yeah he's talented he's leavin 128 and
play the guitar yeah I hope he's ok
health wise i haven't seen him for a
while when I lived in San Francisco we
lived in the upper haight and I would
pass by kids like punk rock kids who
were sitting on the sidewalk begging and
really obnoxious about it too and went
and I was walking home from my second
job of taking the bus from it and walked
by a kid watched him big and then get up
and get into an Audi and drive oh
because they're just like Marin some of
them are yes like you're in punk rock
kids are like [ __ ] you mom I'm gonna go
into the city for the day yeah the
homeless by choice thing I didn't know
that was it that I saw that a lot in
Austin also I saw a bunch i think it was
invented in San Francisco but I still
got him in Minneapolis my sister said we
were living together we both had the two
of the shittiest jobs in the world
and she came home to her apartment uh
with our third roommate and and she said
hey a kid tried to Panhandle be uptown
today in Minneapolis and he was wearing
doc martens so I said I'll give you five
dollars for you doc mark listen anyway
you know what she's cost because yeah
that is why I give you dime none yeah
yes sell your nose ring if you're so
broke and yeah the tattoo thing tattoos
are very expensive I think there is a
point where I wanted a bunch of tattoos
sometimes yes Kennedy no they're very
expensive expenses and permanent and and
yes yeah and so I never did get any
someone a kid that's like got full
sleeves listen eight hundred dollar arms
yeah for a hurry huh really you're not
using your money for education right
right unless there's you know very
sought-after literature written on your
own did you okay do you guys have um
theoretical tattoos i have recently come
up with sort of the joke but not a joke
like if i were a different person
entirely i would have gotten this tattoo
how about you you guys kind of neat i
have mine why don't you get one yeah is
it a butterfly on your lower back it is
a salmon on my lower back is it really
it's i was super drunk it's this story
is boring and I've told you a thousand
times but basically I was with my tattoo
friends who had lots of tattoos now like
let's go get tattoos and we were gonna
get poked Mahone written on our asses
which is Gaelic for kiss my ass I
thought that would be very funny yes
when we got to the tattoo place the
tattoo artist was like no I would have
to make that really big for it to be
readable and a little crazy and no I
won't give you that tattoo so so
everybody had a plan B except for me
drunkle and so I was like it would be
funny if I just get a salmon tattooed
like out of the out of the Fish and Game
book where it literally is it is the
sticker that's on the the truck cab
where if like there's a fisherman that's
like I like to fish for salmon it's that
salmon told the story thousands of dives
but you've never heard it neither am i
yeah so now that's what I have and it
just kind of looks like an old varicose
vein that's luckily in the shape of a
fish horrible terrible mistake dumb only
regrets from the moment it happened just
a really lucky grease shaped well it's
like yeah it just looked it doesn't look
like Jesus now I never right right or
but you know what it is it's the
reminder that I should probably never
start drinking again because that's the
kind of [ __ ] I do when I'm drunk I
soberly got a band-aid tattooed on over
a mistake tattoo that I got with someone
oh my god i have a bandaid on my ankle
and i always thought it might be kind of
funny to have band-aids tattooed on my
knees now but this guy so that's that
would be my joke thing if I ever got I
would get band aids on my elbows knees
or anything that's one of those we know
people who would do that and it's that
kind of thing where comedians are always
liked but this would be the funny thing
to get it's like yeah but then there's
the rest of your life right like you
then you have to go to a funeral with
the you know at band-aids on your elbows
or what it's dark enough I said the word
hose hose I'm a million years that's
right it can i get my coin purse out my
pocket books stuck behind this oh do you
have any certs in there really is some
retson i thought for a minute that if i
would have been drunk and we got tattoos
in 1994 i think i actually would have
gotten night wolf
from Mortal Kombat that's amazing what
does he look like or she American okay
and he has a green glowing tomahawk oh
and he is not in it I would be an
entirely different person I think I
think the tattoo could change somebody
if I'd gotten on my calf a tattoo of
Nighthawk for more altima mortal kombat
or mortal kombat 3 what would be the
difference Jack just give me some
highlights of your day I think it would
have become a sandanista rebel Oh think
it would have gone to Nicaragua
Nicaragua I would um I'd be fighting for
justice you at your thirst for justice
justice would it be unquenchable is
Nicaragua in Indonesia right next to
Kenya they have y de bras well the funny
thing is everyone the manager at a bank
has tattoos on his neck now so sure it
really I don't think it matters anymore
it's talking about some dark hose though
I mean this dr cohn's the tallest or
turtlenecks could not help you my
brother I've told the story about time
my brother Scott got him and his buddy
you know when you're little and your
sister says I turn around now and go
back up this okay okay cool um my sister
when I was very little she said hey
let's cut out each other's hairs and she
kept my hair and then she said no I
don't think it's a good idea ah just
real quick that story is every older
sister younger sister story you just
substitute the nouns they do that to you
over and over you never learn never it
is a Lucy and Charlie Brown the constant
and no I don't feel like it anymore
classic okay sorry good so my brother
Scott did that with tattoos with a buddy
of his when he was 14 and so Scott altar
boy wanted a cross on one shoulder and
he is Henson and
and his buddy 14 year old buddy put a
plus sign because he was agnostic funny
and because he was a mathematician yes
it's kinda since got that fixed in it
turned into a very beautiful army need
cross if such could be Santa yes yes
yeah so beautiful beautiful gorgeous
LeBron gives never been able to bake
corrected hang a left okay uh what is
never been able to be corrected it is
the fact that his buddy tattooed and
Scott must have asked for it Scott's
being honest right no haha I said look
at his own name Scott SEO TT and there's
no way to fix that there's no way to
wait I got caught Scott's name or Scott
made his friend get no that's God's name
oh I would write his own name his own I
mean it would have been different if
Scott was in love with his buddy when
they get 14 but it was that so uh she's
got oh and so he has been able to fix
that one but glad did not get to do his
buddy my friends I have two friends at
home in Montana they always baton and of
course it's like college football or
something that doesn't matter but they
have one of them has a tattoo of him
going behind the other guy like in Ghost
and he's growing up odd yes yes and the
other has a My Little Pony with that
guy's face on his thigh like they have
to get toes if they lose the bet oh yeah
they and it's expensive and they have to
pay for it themselves it's because of a
football game yes right all of those
these are men men brown men with
children and teaching jobs I'm telling
you though and it's great if I met a guy
and he was like can I show you this
tattoo and he opened it up and it was
him and his friend in the ghost position
I would be like I'm deeply in love with
you I need you I need you in my life
would fall in love with Lance Hughes
immediately I plan to use yeah does he
have blond hair no he's a bit of a
redhead oh he's a bit of a special red
head down got a spot over any
he's a big supporter of our podcast oh
hi oh wait I I basically just told
Lansky's I loved him yeah well oh hi
father of seven finally father agree
they're great kids you're gonna love
them you're gonna love him I just got
mom smoking outside what who did I marry
excuse me it's quite alright thank you
Jackie I like this area because I'm
roomie it's well it is roomy and it's
crying out for gentrification leads of
dollars really wants to open up some
sort of bubble coffee shop next to us
bail bondsman bailed next we'll build
the happy dogs when I got my last DUI
you guys um I went to happy dogs when I
was um what when the when the when i was
done being sentenced Jackie when you say
last do you mean most recent or the
final one how many of you had I just too
I can't imagine you getting a DUI and I
don't that's me being judgmental well
can imagine me getting one and never
have gotten more drunk right yes I drove
drunk every day of my life yeah until I
didn't until the second deal until the
last day you drove from until the last
day when I had eight shots of
rumplemintz in 11 years Wow oh eddie i
did a bartender is tumblr glass full of
rumple men yeah which is essentially
just what was it what do you mean it was
clear toothpaste it was a loud
peppermint schnapps yeah and
goldschlager it's a lady proof yeah and
it's goldschlager esque it's dangerous
beverage yes it's Jagermeister
Jagermeister esque God and I had learned
from my first you I when this guy pulled
me over on Laurel Canyon off right off
Laurel Canyon he said ma'am have you
been drinking and I said a lot but I'm
okay oh that's the best it's usually
we're gonna we're gonna kill him with
honesty well the previous DUI the guy
had cult pulled me over and said man if
you've been drinking i said i am drunk
oh and he was like wow so it wasn't
improving please step out of the field
yes good for you just blurting honest I
mean yeah what why prolong a no filter I
don't have a filter sober could you
imagine smokes wait did you stop
drinking entirely yes that I stopped
drinking entire yeah I thought if I
drink anything this is probably gonna
end in tears it or driving which i sees
a lot we're heavy machinery was I'm sure
then the officers of the law get bill
and close to 10 grand oh yeah that's a
great time to try my hand at a tractor
yeah well you know the DUI does not
affect like lawn mowers and firm oh no
good good deed all you want that's it
you can you can drive your putt putt to
that to the local bar yeah yeah good
what you got a couple of do you guys got
gotten a couple of DUI want to get those
under your belt I've not gotten and
don't believe will ever get one now it's
easier to avoid them because you have
luberon things like yeah and I'm an act
of beverage a ver but I'm not gonna for
a month you taking a break I'm gonna
take a break and do a little plans oh
that's a good idea do some navel-gazing
man may be super fun really look inside
do you have to go down to San Diego
where's the nearest base comedy it's a
good time yeah you can slap that Elvis
Costello book if you really need to kiss
me Jackie you mentioned um cuz I saw
some girl scouts today and they they had
they were they were really business
savvy they had rented one of those tent
like pop-up dunes yeah
and they had a mom with him but they
were so organized and silver they said
would you like any cookies today and I I
am my girlfriend with me she had just
bought four boxes and so I said she just
bought something and they interrupted me
and they said well thank you for
supporting the Girl Scouts and I sike oh
man okay i guess i have two more buttons
yes I should about them I don't believe
him I don't want him I don't want to go
to I don't want cookies that's what they
don't know about me is I'm not wish you
to scream that right in their feet oh
wow I don't care if your dad is your
little girl scout ooh girl scout the mom
and dad were they had a wagon full of
girl scout cookies on super bowl sunday
we're going door-to-door alliant the
wagon decorated with balloon animals oh
that's all and the brother the little
brother desperately wanting in on it but
not a girl scout no it was just kind of
hopping around behind the door as they
left here that's why I like the Girl
Scouts they probably would allow that
little brother to be in because the Boy
Scouts or the Cub Scouts are very little
there like homophobe they won't let a
member they don't I don't think they let
gay kids and you guys want to meet Larry
here's my 7-11 oh hey hey Larry buddy oh
yeah the um yeah so ding dong I just
finished recording a dork forest uh-huh
and about the spin John with the door
that's the door but that's adorable
that's the space work that's all you
guys nice it's hard to do on an awesome
you were calling us ding dongs and so I
answer the door and it is an adorable
like six or seven year old mmm and um
hey right here okay uh said via the the
kid
I was like well I don't know there's an
adorable tiny child the girls got
uniform I know how to say no to that
great and my guest sovereign site
sovereign sire oh yeah yes yeah she was
she was like oh I don't know how you
would turn it down and the mom just
grinned and a little boy danced oh and I
bought four boxes cuz she didn't have
change for 20 but she probably did look
can I guess your flavors yep Jackie
Kashian would absolutely do a thin mint
ah the rubble Vince gave it away she's
putting him in the blender remember how
it used to be yeah you're right um and
then I bet you would go first Asamoah is
that what they're called the caramel
chocolate yeah I do connect so yeah
samosas it's like gold samosas are Samoa
yeah and Wyatt I think again I can't eat
it would not to be confused with Samoans
exactly they're larger they're huge and
uh according to a lot of racism quick to
anger it's cookies long my race is
really not yours letters I never just by
reissa sexy super huggable racism says
they're nice phone do did you do a dosey
doe I didn't so just those two those two
oh two boxes of 80 boxes of each um I'm
sorry did I get both yes is exactly
right my new thing I will tell you what
what cookie you like I'll do it you know
what have you thought about a little
side job we're here we're uh we're gonna
tent next to the Girl Scout outside of
the grocery store and let me tell you
what you're gonna get yeah well gain a
crystal ball and I'll this just start
screaming lemon cream at people as they
walk up and like the crucible you can
just pointed yellow kind of a kind of
good Jackie we just basically this is do
you needed run an errand yeah that's
what just happened this is exactly not
as catchy but I know you have a show and
I do so make you like you're so right
here's the weird thing is I need a ride
to the airport but I wouldn't ask anyone
to drive me to the airport for a 10am
flight to LAX from here yeah because
then you would have to get me
around 8-830 right then come back up the
405 don't do that job we started we've
been yeah we've been doing fewer LAX
ride part of our original I call it
mission statement but I wish I could say
something else well ed told me that he
would drive me because Andy always
drives me I mean we've been together too
long for him still to be picking me up
at the airport don't you think no no no
if anything that's he's he's legally
been bound to this one hundred percent
because what a better way well Burbank
but LAX that's a test of your love it's
a total test of my lungs how you know
you know what I I every single time I
say I could take the flyaway every
second guys you guys know about the
plywood they drop you off so nice but
then you have to wait for them to pick
up every other person in Los Angeles
County yeah you don't you have to go to
the Flyway and they like to change the
way you pay for it sometimes it's cash
sometimes it's a credit card sometimes
they only take debit cards sometimes you
have to bring a chicken really bad with
the feet sticking out right and it used
to be like two bucks which of course is
absurd a ride from Van Nuys to the to
the airport yeah and now it's eight
which is still pretty decent how do they
make money off of that I think it's
subsidized by the US government oh icic
I think Bernie Sanders has something to
do yeah I walked you can walk a mile
from my house and get on the city bus
and it's one dollar and they take you to
LAX but there's too many things that
might go wrong variable yeah risky too
many knives yes yes too many plus the
walking yeah there is your with your
with all my luggage and my teacher you
know my koozies my posters stickers the
limited edition posters yes um I have
them so much merge by the way I have a
stand-up comic I don't know anyone who
has more items than i do and sells less
stuff i like to bring a lot of different
choices it's about choice these days
it's about choices you're smart somebody
likes to always come up and say do you
have them in like a woman's cut haha do
I my American Apparel you just pull out
some scissors and cut the shirt
you go roses are there you go during the
air and toss a switchblade at it what's
your show tonight I'm doing it's after
the super super bowl it's called the
nerd bowl I don't know what it means all
i know is that flappers asked me if I
knew any nerds that I was like yeah yeah
sure do and I said Dan Telfer yeah so
he's gonna kiss a Larry other team of
nerds oh cool then I don't know who else
is on the show but I told him a bunch of
comics that are letter complete dorks
and then what are you doing like a quiz
bowl thing like trivia or I don't know
call assume i'm just i'm planning on
doing react thought what the heck of
course that's why you should do yes
sometimes there's this homework shows
though that you had to come and do a
whole different I did Largo the other it
was bringing the rock and i catered my
whole set to this van halen moment that
i had and but then everyone else kind of
did their material and ended with a
thing yes right and i was like man I
really wish I'd done that yeah
especially a bar go I've only done bring
the rock once as a person who knows my
aim is true disgust oh uh you could
imagine how it went it didn't go well
could I get ready to talk about music
and I don't know enough about it I have
their yours playing in ke rakh ke Jackie
right now is a song that Aaron Burr sex
in the musical Hamilton Jackie it's
aaron burr solo hey thanks for the ride
of course my coffee yeah please don't
say no you so much for being our Super
Bowl guess you're doing great yeah yeah
we did we did well we did it we got it
done thanks guys any do you want to plug
anything yeah well I do stand-up comedy
and I have a podcast called the door for
us plus I have the new podcast Laurie
Kilmartin where little did I know people
have always wanted to hear me [ __ ]
about stand-up comedy well that's under
economic that's right uh so Laurie
Kilmartin I unnoticed oh that's what's a
call on a lorry and Jackie the Jackie
Laurie show I did you name it that's a
great visit the Jackie Lord show and I
always called glory Jackie should all
see because you're both not selfish
that's right we give and we give
I women comics give too much as doing
laps yeah anyway he's nervous about the
game yeah we're down to the wire all
right I'm gonna drive the flappers you
guys I gotta go get my car out of hock
but thanks for driving us course of
course Thank You Jackie vodka sake
you've been listening to do you need a
ride dyn AR I leave in are you on way
battle either way we wanna be there
doesn't matter how much baggage you
clean give us time and a terminal
we want to send you up inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her was it fine now
haha
do you need a ride do you need a mind do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need with Karen and Chris
you